je pense que nous avons nous allons
révolutionner le traitement de la
douleur
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui est encore malheureusement
les facultés de médecine
une enceinte ni la douleur en profondeur
jamais comment examiner quelqu'un en
douleur pour dépister la douleur
neuropathique est enceinte
aucune main la toxicomanie c'est quoi ça
avec le temps la société va apprendre
que oui ça peut être un outil très très
importants dans certaines maladies la
douleur le stress post traumatique la
fibromyalgie etc
on va être en mesure à ce moment-là de
démontrer au ministère la santé que
c'est un traitement valable qui non
seulement est pas un dividende en légère
fonctionnelles etc soulager leur douleur
leur permet de dormir mais aussi ivres
épargné pour inna mullan de sommes
d'argent au gouvernement
étant donné qu'on s'en sera de prescrire
les médicaments la tonne de co
analgésiques et les opiacés puis ensuite
tous les problèmes des opc tous leurs
pièces et c'est une dame par exemple qui
a subi une opération que les hémorroïdes
il ya plusieurs années et depuis ce
temps là une sensation de bulma de
douleurs des chocs électriques
incapables de s'asseoir sans des
coussins etc prenait des grosses doses
de narcotiques
on a commencé lorsqu on a trouvé notre
dos l atout délaissé ce qui est encore
soutenait ce que nous avons appris ce
que les gens délaissent leur pc avec le
moindre symptôme de sevrage